[Applause]
okay so that will turn into machine
learning okay well since the
introduction to Hydra physics took a lot
of the time I thought I would jump to
some areas which has great potential for
machine learning and also where the
first hints of concrete project a
progress and I'll try to include those
okay so there are a number of areas
where we could improve things a lot over
our traditional methods potentially
first you saw about triggering how we do
the real-time filtering of data to end
up with tolerable amounts of computing
and storage needed to extract the
potential new signals and also the very
operation of having many of these sites
cooperate in terms of distributing the
data storing it at the right places or
places which are favorable where many
people can get at it more easily and
having both an efficient and predictable
time to complete certain operations on
their global ensemble of sites that's
also something where we could we could
really benefit from new methods both in
terms of optimization and coming up with
stable solutions in terms of the physics
itself there are a number of areas we're
starting to go after one is a new
tracking algorithms for the charged
particle trajectories that you saw we're
identifying objects for simulating
things faster and also in the end also
well low energy computation means a form
of computation and exascale systems that
we haven't emphasized so much so far
so this is just sort of to give you a
sense of the problem how we deal with
tracking now so you see a sort of
generic you know detector with layers
where charge particles going through
provide you coordinates in order to from
the mass of hits that you see in the
upper left how to extract the particle
trajectories remembering that you have
not only the interaction of interest but
also many so-called pileup interactions
which are not basically of interest how
you go about from these many many spaced
points getting the trajectories going
through space so first the general
technique is you do what's called
seeding you try to find some track stubs
one advantage is the inner layers of the
tracking detector tends to be a two
dimensional detector called the pixel
detector when you readout x and y and so
you can make a stub in 3-space and then
you can go around to the next layers
which i'll basically give you a
coordinate in one dimension well one
dimension that's measured and then there
are different positions of these strips
to build a track and we use a method
which is most often used as a Kalman
filter or variation of that the
combinatorics as you'd expect are
enormous and so the time invested is
also very large and as the complexity of
the events goes up with the amount of
pileup it becomes more and more of a
challenge and eventually it could be a
dominating factor in our computational
limits of our computational ability and
therefore to take best advantage of the
data in the future so this has been one
focus another is we realize that we
spend really billions of computing hours
making simulations so I describe the
process by which particles interact with
the material in the detector and through
various processes which thanks to the
question I got some of which I got to
describe you end up with electronic
signals so this shows a picture
here of an electron coming into one of
these crystals and then the electron
first radiates in the in the presence of
the heavy material of heavy atoms and
then the photons convert and then the
the secondary electrons and positrons
then again interact and get a whole
cascade and a huge number of secondary
electrons and and and photons which are
tracked in these simulations and
eventually you get a measure of how much
energy is collected in each crystal and
then the light is propagated to the
photo sensor and this photo sensor
creates a signal and this representation
of digitalization and it takes a long
time so the question is could be not
somehow instead of doing this ab initio
simulation of all these details somehow
have a higher-level representation for
example through generative models that
would short-circuit this enormous
computational time the next is
calorimeter reconstruction this shows
some of the crystals which are in that
layer light is produced and then if you
look at the time dependence there's an
electronic signal from the photo
detector which is then amplified and you
get this shape this particular signal
now with tile up you actually get the
superposition of many of those and we
actually have an algorithm that
untangles up to about ten of those
within that short time interval and
again isn't there a better way to do
your clustering from all these hits in
the calorimeter and then to extract the
information you want in terms of pattern
recognition and identification then
regression two to give you the measure
of for example the energy of the
particle that initiated all of this is
the untangling just based on
clustering my proximity or is there a
characteristic shape that you there are
characteristic shapes as was mentioned
they're not all that well defined so one
would have to allow for a whole range of
shapes what you're seeing also is so
that would apply more to what happens on
the right in the middle you also see in
time so that's a simpler thing and
actually the first attempt to untangle
up to 10 of those pulses has worked
rather well because of exactly what you
said that's an electronic preamplifier
readout it has a very characteristic
shape and therefore the decomposition
into multiple signals of a given shape
that was relatively straightforward I
have to say that even they're not until
you were to revisit it to see if you can
do better
we don't know another subtle statement I
can make is looking at our ability to
reconstruct photons there's maybe a
missing 1% there may be a source of a 1%
resolution that we don't quite
understand so you look at that as a
problem or an opportunity so we're
hoping and I'll refer to some recent
work by Maria and Don Rock Lima who
works with her and some of our students
on trying to take a lesson from scene
labeling work you know how you have a
complex scene how you identify objects
and what you but even more than that
identifying the objects turns out to be
something that we are doing with our
traditional methods but how you compose
the scene you know what is this event
that's that's where some recent progress
has been made okay so let me skip over
the early things till later things so
some of the things which have been done
there was a pilot program to try to do
better and now we're starting to do
better in terms of multiple Jets so in
an event
let's say I have a B quark which forms a
jet of particles because quarks don't
appear in nature that if a.w particle is
produced when it decays it decays most
of the time in to two quarks and that
creates two Jets but if they're
high-energy particles there's a boost
right remember relative moves for those
who remember any physics so then things
get folded together and how do you
untangle it
so gluons can be identified because they
tend to be wider and have subjects which
are different from the case of a core
and so there's been some progress in
identifying gluon jets from quark Jets
there was some work done a couple of
years ago neural network methods to
discriminate events containing the top
quark but I'll show something along this
lines which are better also in the
trigger which can be done very fast and
then also this is really something which
has had actually had a physics outcome
so in a different class of experiments
where I have a very heavy detectors
which detect neutrinos so this is the
nova experiment what happens is
neutrinos produced at Fermilab goes 700
kilometers to a large detector in in
North Dakota and from there every once
and while some neutrinos actually
interact and one of the important
processes is ones in which an electron
is produced so you have neutrinos which
are really because of the way the
produce of the muon type and then when
they travel they some of them change
into a different type of neutrino the
electron type and you see them if they
interact and produce an electron but
those events are hard to pick out and
very few and a big struggle was made to
identify the electron events one of my
former students actually Alex Mo was the
one who came up with this technique of
using essentially a convolutional neural
network they calls it a some reason
visual network because I guess the
visual patterns are quite different
between the signal events and the
background events and by applying this
he was able to get 40% better electron
efficiency with the same background and
it's a faster method than what we had
before before we used to we have a
library of showers of these interactions
and maybe 30 million of them and try to
find the best pattern match and that
took a long time and also was limited in
it in its efficiency ok so here are some
recent work this is something you should
follow up with Maria when she visits
here I think next month so we've been
looking at a 3d imaging of LHC data
energy regression and particle
identification for example we'll have a
new forward calorimeter for the phase 2
at the LHC event classification using
particle level information I'll say more
about that charge particle tracking
acceleration so we're starting to look
at that I would say we have a ways to go
and distributed learning so learning how
to paralyze some of these computational
methods and so a high degree of
parallelism for example on jet
identification has been done running a
large facilities with many GPUs and then
also Maria and John Rocker won't see
much more about it have been looking at
neuromorphic hardware for online data
processing and event selection okay so
this is highlighting some of the data
science and energy physics workshops
that she has been running since 2015
2016 was at the Simons Foundation in New
York and if some references to some
results shown there and the latest one
was at Fermilab so focus is on new ideas
and solutions in tracking as I said
calorimetry detecting anomalies that can
mean finding rare events it can also
mean that you can apply it to online
operations of the
and instead of humans looking at all
these distributions online and deciding
if something is wrong having it done
automatically and much faster so I mean
the idea is not only to investigate
these methods but also to develop new
paradigms at least applications and to
collaborate in in developing perhaps
also some innovative approaches okay so
there are three papers at the last nips
workshop and I'll refer to a couple of
them so the first is the so-called deep
topology classifiers this involves
you'll see the various methods that we
use then calorimetry particle
classification regression and simulation
and I won't say too much about the tract
reconstruction it's more on the side of
an initial investigation alright so this
is from a student with some results
which are fairly recent
so the idea it started in the summer of
2016 there was a student from Berkeley
Danny why to come and continued with a
focus on how to apply this in the CMS
high level trigger the part which is
done with normal processors but one
could also imagine also applying GPUs
and then finally we got to this abstract
image classification where different
types of particles which are come out of
our first stages of reconstruction or
them represented as simple shapes and
how the pattern of shapes on a plane
which essentially is unrolling the
two-dimensional angular range that
covered by the experiment how they could
be used to distinguish different types
of events so this is a poster that was
shown there I'll go through some of this
so the problem is that the trigger has a
non negligible false positive rate in
trying to pick out for example if I'm
trying to pick
events which come from the production of
a top quark and other top quark this was
the target of this study you can have
simple criteria like a single electron
or muon comes out but some rare events
with nothing but jets contaminate this
and this means you have to take a lot of
events and store them for further
analysis so you waste a lot of CPU time
and a lot of storage so the point is can
you filter away a lot of the false
positives with these new methods so this
is a kind of representation about how it
works first you generate the particles
in the simulation as four vectors and
you have three subclasses produced
according to the rate you know from the
standard model how often you produce a
top fork and at the top quark maybe I
can use this as a sample of such events
there's a sample of events with so
called QCD with jets and a sample with a
W boson together with jets because the W
can sometimes produce a lepton and then
you reconstruct it with this fast
program called Delphis and it gives out
particles you call so do a pre selection
so it makes it a little bit harder
actually to do the discrimination which
is good in this study and you see that
the problem is that if you want to pick
these things out in the trigger that
almost all the events according to the
predictions are going to be QCD events
even after the selection and w+ jets in
a little little sliver heater which if
you add up the percentages is like one
event in 200 is a top fork and the top
worker man so the student tung oil tried
the various methods one is a particle
sequence classifier i'll describe what
that is the sequence of particles is in
a certain order is taken as input to a
recurrent neural network
the abstract image classifier which I'll
describe in a little bit more detail and
a high level feature classifier just
using some high-level features of the
events and inputting it to a fully
connected deep neural network this one
the pictures didn't come out very well
they'll try to lead you through all the
information from the cells but you would
tend to get by just sort of imaged
what's happening in the calorimeter x' I
get various cells with different amounts
of energy but it's kind of scattered and
a convolutional neural network doesn't
do well with this kind of sparse data
where I have important pixels but
they're kind of disparate you know
they're not contiguous regions so the
idea is why not put transform it through
a kind of filter where instead of this
pixels you just knowing what you think
from our reconstructing stages of
reconstruction of the particles just put
an image there and so the different
types of images you can sort of see in
black and white if you look carefully
you'll see squares and Pentagon's and in
circles and so that's what makes it up
so first I'll come back to that first a
fully connected high-level feature deep
neural network classifier there are 14
high-level features so if I take you
through there are various things like
the total amount of energy that you see
flowing transverse to the beamline
looking in a plane perpendicular to the
beam line where the missing energy is
how much of it there is you know telling
you about neutrinos for example when it
W the case there are neutrinos how many
jets how many B Jets if there are
leptons
what is its momentum transverse to the
beam line the angles with respect to the
beam line how isolated it is and so on
and so this is the network that was used
with three hidden layers shown there and
then the outputs being a three-way
classifier W pledged adds keeps
the titi bar the next one is particle
sequence classifier the particles are
ordered according to increasing or
decreasing distance from the isolated
laptop so you take the lepton as sort of
us the guiding thing that's telling you
about the class of the event and then
try to look at all the other particles
and try to help with the distinction the
topology of all the tracks relative to
those leptons and tried various things
Delta R is a kind of measure in two
dimensional space there are two angles
as an angle respect to the beam line we
actually use the transformation of that
because it's it's invariant to a boost
along the beam line but let's say it's a
measure of two angles and then the
individual angles the answer mutual
direction in the polar direction should
you consider the momentum transverse to
that lepton of the other tracks it turns
out that this first Delta R was the best
and that the best ordering feeding into
there is decreasing distance from the
lepton and so was fed in through this
so-called this network with a so-called
gated recurrent units and then to do the
classification and there's some
technical things at the bottom about how
it was run on a single GPU
okay so here are the results so the
different techniques the particle
sequence classifier the abstract image
classifier with different types of
polygons essentially representing
different types of particles and circles
were used to represent the missing ét
missing energy and the high level
feature classifier and so you can see
the results the so-called Rockler which
is the signal efficiency on the vertical
versus the background contamination
probability on the horizontal axis and
you can see that relative to the red
curve which is our classic way of doing
this the red curve there's tremendous
improvement in terms of what you can
achieve in terms of much lower
background contamination for a given
signal efficiency so for example you can
have an efficiency of 99 percent in the
best case with a very little background
in fact you can reduce the background
you have to store by an order of
magnitude excuse me yeah this is to be
run online after the triggers but before
you actually store anything yeah the
idea is to eventually to deploy this in
the trigger so how long do you have to
reach your decision I mean that's a good
question I mean basically it's going to
be a sort of a fraction of a second but
remember it is the training and the
inference so the inference can be fast
and if we do this in the trigger I sort
of skipped over it here this is I think
the kind of thing you should raise with
Maria who's more deeply involved in this
but one would imagine that for the
inference you'd look in the real-time
system perhaps of complementing the
classical processors with FP
or something just to be able to do this
at a high rate
okay so then there's this calorimetry
with deep learning and so I just sort of
showing the results again so you're
trying to identify particles and there
are two cases here one is to distinguish
a photon from a PI zero the PI zero or
neutral pion always decays into two
photons but if the PI zero is a high
momentum then the two photons are close
together so it's it's somewhat different
could be somewhat difficult and
distinguishing it and so here to make it
harder they've actually picked out a
particles which are difficult so for
neutral players that where the photons
are really close together within 1% of a
radian separation and in the case of a
charged pions which are trying again to
distinguish from photons ones where in
the detector very little energy escapes
from the layer which for us would be the
crystal this is I think in a more
generic detector the same idea that you
have PI ons which normally would put a
lot of our energy in the Hadron
calorimeter
but in these pre-selected cases they
don't and then to make it harder and to
show what kind of discrimination can be
achieved so in the case of the photon
versus PI 0 with respect to the booster
dishes entry methods which are the
previous methods there's an improvement
where you gain 9% in signal efficiency
but more importantly you can reduce the
background by 40% at the usual working
point on this plot and then for photon
versus positive PI on it's even more
dramatic so you can get 99.4% efficiency
which is a 5% boost and efficiency but
the background is 150 times less and so
I tried to put dots so this is before
you see the fact that this one is really
up really up very high so you can you
can move this point back you can move to
the left and still get very high
efficiency but we
very low background and the numerical
results are summarized in the table down
here the Delta our background is the
ratio of a background for the the new
method versus the booster decision tree
there's a reduction effect of 150 right
so then there was the hope of generative
models of being able to make images and
then classify things including new
patterns based upon what you observe and
so this is the work that was referred to
earlier done by Atlas about shower
Generation so there are a couple of nice
papers which came out this year this is
one of them which talks about this so
called Calgon it's a generative
adversarial networks for calorimeter
shower production and so so this is the
layout this is shows you can find this
talk online but there are three layers
with unequal resolution and they share
the energy longitudinally and you get a
profile a characteristic shape in each
of the three layers you remember that
and the other thing I talked about
neutrino experiment they took in their
case different case huge library of
shower simulated showers to try to match
I mean this is a lot better than that so
what they're doing well so in Atlas
there are essentially three layers in
their calorimeter so you have the
electromagnetic layer which is rather
fine-grained and then the Hadron
calorimeter layer and a sort of tail
catcher at the end and they have
different granularities
so when you do the grounds up simulation
like in this program which is happens to
be called J on to j on for is like the
fourth version you get all these points
so all that ab initio simulation of
actions of the material in the material
of the primary and all those secondary
particles happens this is an
electromagnetic shower so I get a shower
of electrons and positrons there but
what you really read out is shown on the
right where you can see that there are
some channels and the color represents
how much energy was deposited in the
cell and you can see there are you know
relatively few cells in the three
different layers alright so this is the
generative adversarial Network most
people in the audience know more about
this than I do since I'm learning this
rather recently and this is some of the
results so you look at the different
layers in the first layer you have a
small sample just to illustrate of some
patterns in the first layer and then the
best match which comes out of the
generative I have a serial network and
then in the second layer and then the
best match you see for the real case you
see five of them and the second layer
and then you can see the best match from
the network and then in the third layer
if you look at the global features of
what comes out for example the
distribution in the in the energy in
each of the three layers you can see the
distribution matches fairly well but if
you look at the CPU power it's really a
tremendous advance so the JNA for time
to generate a shower is a 1.8 seconds
and then using classical CPUs from one
to a thousand of them how many
milliseconds it would take but the GPU
is actually tremendously well-suited for
this and so you know running these
things in parallel you can go from one
point eight seconds down to twelve
microseconds and this was demonstrated I
was at the I ran a set of demonstrations
at the supercomputing conference and one
of them that we hosted was a live
demonstration of this technique where
large numbers of showers were generated
and then the images were moved to
University of Chicago and Michigan from
the place to facilities so facilities
were run at at Berkeley Lab for example
and some other sites where they have
lots of GPUs and then moved for further
analysis
and storage at Chicago and Michigan then
this shows the the training going on
moving the shower images to disk in the
middle and the utilization of the GPU
and so in two days they produce 205
million showers
now the last thing I wanted to talk
about is moving towards this tracking
machine learning challenge these slides
actually come from David Russo and so I
showed this one is to keep in mind that
the pre-plea the following one's also
are from him just to give an indication
so the idea is that we want to optimize
the tracking you remember the generic
layering of a high energy physics
detector with a tracker and calorimeters
than muon systems outside and so this
focus is on the tracker and the reason
is that it takes so much CPU time so the
tracking is what dominates the
reconstruction CPU time as the pileup
continues to go up it's becoming more
and more of a problem the growth in
spite of our code improvements seems to
be growing somewhere between
quadratically and exponentially and if
you want to go up to 200 it's not even
clear at the moment what the number is
like there and you can see also a
picture in a kind of generic detector or
a simulation of all the hits you get in
the tracker and then and then some of
the calorimeter is outside ok so we
expect the CPU power $4 to to increase
of course I mean but only about a factor
of 10 in 10 years taking the trends that
we see now I mean this is before there
are physics changes in you know we're
not talking about post silicon
electronics or computers beyond what we
do now in terms of silicon based
processors so we only expect a factor of
10 the experiments that data taking rate
will also increase by a factor of 10 but
the events are tremendously more complex
because of pileup and we'd like to have
a reconstruction technique that allows
us to look at events for the
hundred-fifty pileup or maybe 200
and have a familiar reconstruction time
like what we had at 20 Pilate so we need
a very significant speed-up factor of
somewhere between ten and a hundred and
so how are we going to do that well like
I have said our field looks at itself as
fairly mature in terms of having
investigated how to do improve tracked
reconstruction for a long time but given
the progress in other areas it looks
like possible maybe even likely that we
can do better and so the idea of this
tracking challenge which will be is in
the process of being formulated and will
soon be proposed is to tackle this
problem collaboratively between our
community and machine learning community
this was an example I when I spoke here
last time I did remotely actually I
refer to this tracking technique so
there are there were for example in the
2014 nips conference examples of
tracking you see on the left for
cyber-physical systems you see various
tracks for planes and then a clutter of
birds and then to understand you know
how to have the various tracks not
collide with each other of encounter of
the birds or on a soccer field but this
is somewhat different
you know it's for us we're we're
worrying about the CPU time rather than
you know whether there's an accident or
something like that
there's also the experience of the the
Higgs machine learning challenge which
ran in 2014 and this also helps set the
direction for this for this challenge
how will work in practice there were
2000 participants you know Cargill runs
these challenges that was perhaps the
biggest challenge they had in terms of
participation the best significance that
was achieved is 20 was already 20%
better than with the usual Hydra physics
tools called T MVA which is a
multivariate analysis tool set the
booster decision tree algorithm of
choice the boost of the sidon tree was
was the best no I don't remember yes
it's actually boost and I found this
very interesting I came across this
myself recently that when we say boost
decision tree we don't mean that but
it's rather well-known it seems in the
computer science community that actually
boost extreme gradient boosting is the
best type of boost decision tree and
there were many ideas which are
documented in this Proceedings of a
workshop at nips 2014 I wrote down the
reference for you and its function was
to show that some people can do better
or not in our community and also raised
awareness about machine learning in
hydro physics so this is a table of
results and the top three winners you
know get some money and you see the
score in the middle there but the best
physicist was only eighth and it seems
that he dropped from the previous year
or something by seven places and the
best person in terms of using the
traditional tools T MBA was was down
here
he was number 782 so that's a lesson and
he had dropped 149 places so the idea
again this is David Russo's a slide
is okay we have a problem so over years
we develop solutions and then the idea
is that you present your problem in a
simplified way so you people can deal
with it in a straightforward way through
another community they address the
problem and they solve the problem maybe
it's better maybe and then Yuri
importnat the exact solution because you
have a simplified problem but the
approach and the methodology and you get
some benefit and another way this has
been presented oh yeah so there was sort
of wondering about how much time it
takes to do this so this is a nice
picture which was presented in 2014 so
imagine that we are the traditional
experts and what you see on the x-axis
is the value of our ideas and so we get
a certain value you know it's not little
somewhere in the middle and it's rather
well defined and then maybe
non-traditional people come along and a
lot of the ideas maybe don't do as well
because we've been working on it for
years but there's some evidence that the
upper tail of the non-traditional
participants goes beyond what we do
that's the idea
not only a machine learning but in
general how it works with innovation
it's a nice a nice illustration now
remember this is a cpu challenge so the
next slide here is to have been CPU
challenges this is the Harvard Medical
School content contest for biology big
data problem a big data problem in
genomics and the focus was to get the
results in terms of how you to carry
this out in other words to sequence what
is the best result in terms of correct
sequencing about also considering the
time so in this plot the time is on a
log scale and the best in-house
solutions of the yellow and the red so
on the vertical axis
the score in terms of correctness is
pretty high but it takes an enormous
amount of time the exceptions and then
there's these other the challenge
submissions the whole cluster over here
so they got the same or in some cases
better score in terms of being nearer to
perfect but you can see that it was sort
of ten to a hundred times faster so it
says you can annotate ten million
sequences in less than three minutes or
a quarter billion sequences in about an
hour and a laptop so that gives you
motivation
so here's high-energy physics tracking
looks nice once you have the tracks
before you have the tracks it looks like
that and so the hope here is that this
fascinates machine learning experts
right we hope and so we hope with this
challenge to engage them there are some
early results done from within the
community but never mind okay now the
other thing which is gets back a bit to
physics there are a lot of parameters to
the value of the result in this
challenge many of the tracks in that
mess of points are not of interest so
low momentum tracks are everywhere and
they're rarely associated with the event
of interest we care about high momentum
tracks we sometimes care about tracks
which are in the middle there are
momentum with the middle of very dense
Jets of particles we care about tracks
which come from this place for vertices
for example if we produce a beat quark
remember the most common decay of a
Higgs boson this to a bottom quark and
an anti bottom quark it forms a particle
Amazon and then when it decays it often
that the vertex is displaced so it comes
out of the primary vertex you don't see
it you know you see a track but then at
the cage later
so tracks from displaced vertices may be
particularly important may be electrons
I think the question mark is because
because of the showering of electrons
even in the tracker maybe it's
considered difficult but very low
what momentum tracks have nearly zero
weight okay so the point again to say is
that let's see another is a pattern
recognition so we know how to get once
we know the points on a track we know
how to get the track parameters so we're
not asking for improved measurements of
the track parameters the main part of
this problem is the pattern recognition
identifying which points belong to the
track so that's a big challenge and will
be coming out I mean they're already
hackathons and people already starting
to try but it will be advertised and be
a challenge in the next a month now
one thing I just learned is a current
example of deep learning for real
physical examples physically
advancements and so this has to do with
picking out Jets that come from bottom
quarks and from charm quarks and how
it's being applied so the idea for
example if I want to identify a top
quark one of the one of the handles is
that the top quark 100% of the time goes
to a bottom quark then there's a W boson
which later can lead to two more Jets
over a lepton and neutrino and if I'm
looking at the Higgs boson one of the
things which is most difficult for us is
to identify the Higgs boson when it
decays to a bottom quark and at the
bottom quark so that'd be tagging on the
right on your picture is used in about
30% of the seven hundred publications
we've had so far and it's the seventh
most the technical paper about it has
been the seventh most cited journal
publication
that's the old method okay so now this
is about the concept of heavy particle
identification so let's say that a B
quark is produced it flies a certain
distance you see the the dashed line
from the primary vertex this is P be the
primary vertex and then there's a
secondary vertex worth the case a
lifetime in its rest frame it's only one
one-and-a-half picoseconds but because
the Lorentz boost remember there's time
dilation so it flies a bit further and
in for high energy B quarks you get
displacements from a few millimeters up
to a centimeter so you can use that if
you consider that the secondary tracks
which are associated with the secondary
vertex and reconstructing very mass of
these things will get a larger mass
because it came from a heavier cork and
you also sometimes will see instead a
lepton if you see that you also get a
neutrino so it's not really a mass
reconstruction problem but you get
another handle on identification so use
these things to construct the variables
to discriminate between bond and quarks
charm quarks and the light the lighter
quarks and this is useful for various
searches for new physics for example so
they tried various methods after years
the best method before was the CSV SV is
for secondary vertex and there was a
neural network with a single hidden
layer there are 20 inputs about the
track and secondary vertex and about 20
to 40 nodes in the single hidden layer
and the app would essentially be quark
versus like pork so it's a kind of
binary classifier now in the new case
that this thing called the deep CSV and
there you see a deep neural network with
a hundred nodes in each of two hidden
layers and now it's more than a binary
classifier so puts out the probability
of
B and an anti B or just a B or C and n
ty C or a single C or like forks whoops
I hit the wrong button
I was
okay so this was applied so you're
looking for a rare production of four
top quarks and I mean this could be a
sign of of something beyond the standard
model basically standard model doesn't
give you much but if there's something
beyond the standard model
there are heavier partners in these some
of these theories to the top quarks you
can get a higher production rate so the
question here is what is the limit on
the production rate in terms of the mass
of the extra particle that could be
giving you this namely imagine there's a
heavy resonance called X and at the case
to two Higgs bosons and then from there
it goes to four B Forks so what is the
limitation on the so-called
cross-section which is a measure of the
production rate versus the mass of X and
if you look carefully you'll see
following so the classical method okay
is a green which looks not too bad but
if you start to look the new deep neural
networks and there are three of them
with different criteria there's loose
medium and tight what does it mean loose
means you accept 10% background medium
means you accept only 1% background type
means only 0.1% background if you make
it too tight you start to run out of
Statistics so indeed you find that the
best limit which is the lower one is the
blue which is the deep neural network
secondary vertex finder with the medium
tightness criterion and it's the blue
curve and you compare that to the green
curve and you see it's already the best
one which is impressive because we
haven't been doing that for this long
the other is some
the performance in terms of the
efficiency and misidentification
probability for such secondary vertices
and you have to then say what are you
talking about are you talking about
distinguishing a bottle court from a
light cork which is the solid curves or
are you talking about now
distinguishing a bottle cork from the
somewhat heavy but lighter Trump courts
with DES curves and so I see one of my
little circles is still left over so I
put these little circles there to show
where you are with the new method which
is the the purple solid curves on the
right it doesn't do that much better
with a misidentification probability of
one percent but if then you look for
very pure samples and go down here then
you find that it is the best method and
then in distinguishing bottom quarks
from top quarks it's the - curve and if
I want to do that with one percent
background contamination is definitely
the best so the next thing is to go on
remember the Higgs goes to to a bottom
fork and my bottom quark post often and
we've done a search for that and we
could normalize to see how well we're
doing because this is a known process
where the Z which has a mass of 91 GV
the Higgs hundred twenty-five we could
look for this and in fact we see that so
we know we're doing okay and then set
try to find this now there have been
measurements of that but this is a very
particular case where the Higgs has a
large momentum transverse to the
beamline
and so it's telling you something about
the dynamics of the Higgs as well okay
so now you have this BB tiger and so
this is not yet using deep neural
network it's about - and I actually have
the sum of the first results coming but
you can see again the new curves are the
blue car
and you can see on this so-called plots
the rock plots with signal efficiency
versus miss identification probability
in this case you look carefully you see
it's reverse the misidentification
probability is on the vertical axis and
the tagging efficiency is on the
horizontal axis of the best curves move
down and to the right and you can see
that the new technique is doing the best
it's already being used but then point
is now to improve it further with a deep
neural network technique
having seen the experience with a single
B quark production and in fact it was
applied already in that first exercise
where you look for the Higgs to be b bar
using these techniques and you see some
indication it's not yet significant 1.5
sigma but z 2 b bar was seen as an
observation with five sigma which is
good and it's very important to to
improve this further so that's worth
going on right now okay so we have some
takeaway messages which are big messages
you could see we're just starting to get
into this field machine learning for us
has a lot of promise because we have
computational problems a lot of
complexity in our methods enormous
computational time and so perhaps
learning from things like scene labeling
or another from another perspective the
deep neural networks can also provide us
advantages in ways that we never
suspected before we want to apply it
both for real-time event filtering in a
so-called trigger and also for analysis
and also perhaps reduced the time for
simulation while I didn't have time to
talk about today is this worldwide
system for workflow for computation and
data storage and data flowing over
networks and we are building intelligent
systems to try to deal with the
complexity of those but once we set
those up then also that would be a
a fertile field for machine learning and
that one will have a sort of global
impact immediately because what we do
challenges the world's networks and if
we improve those systems we can improve
them not only for a science field but
for everyone and in the end the bottom
line here is that we hope that by using
these methods in many areas we're going
to gain greater insight than we have
before greater insight and how to solve
our problems greater insight in terms of
new scientific discoveries well so you
see those are early exercises and if you
look carefully at the computational
setup they're rather simple so you know
I think it's basically a computation
problem we are getting scaling among
many GPUs but haven't really dealt with
the issue of the relative connectivity
between the GPUs and inside GPUs so I
make a very complex neural network I'm
gonna have a problem in a single few
memory limited yes for the last bit how
do you know what the ground truth is
fine misidentification probability how
do I know if you you're saying visit the
game's probability is like 1% in order
to estimate that you need to know what
the god truth is yeah we use simulation
to do that and essentially so there are
always two sides of the coin one is to
use to make better measurements of
processes you understand and then to
apply it you know with a slight
extrapolation into an unknown area so
for example we'd like to get better
measurements of Higgs to BB bar we
measure Z
to be reborn on process we get the right
break we see that we'd make an
observation we said we're doing okay and
now this is how we just translate it to
the slightly different case different
math so the heat is going to be D bar
then I guess they seem like the most
interesting thing for you to finally
said that you're not expecting
yes so this is a few general statements
about that so for us in this language it
translates into what's called anomaly
detection so can you just look at the
data and say that something is wrong
there was a trap maybe it's like a bear
trap it's like there was a very bright
young faculty member at MIT my knew well
and he built tools like that not using
machine learning but using some other
methods the point is that if I have an
enormous data set and I just want to
look for anomalies remember there are
things that cannot calculate so there
are rare processes and some of them are
either beyond being calculated
accurately and others are just beyond
calculation so we use finding diagrams
right and fireman diagrams the
philosophy is you have the initial state
the final state you have to draw all
diagrams which start from this and so it
explodes there are new methods to do
certain things there's things called
scattering amplitudes there's certain
things you can calculate way faster than
that but you cannot sort of do a
complete calculation so within our data
there are certain things we cannot
calculate accurately so for example if I
look at all distributions and say is
there something that doesn't agree with
the prediction so sure there is what we
tend to do is look at our data and when
we're looking for a particular signal go
into control region use the data and
then do an extrapolation or
interpolation because we know there's
always something buried in there so how
to say I've experienced something like
that so I'll talk in those terms if
there was something that really stood
out not just a
deviation and certain distributions but
really an anomaly so we would go through
a few things first a very deep
investigation that there were no
detector effects or anomalies in in how
we took the data then you start to go
after so according to my calculations
this could not have happened in the
standard model I don't have a model for
it and then you go after you know how
limited was my calculation final thing
which is what we do live through is this
and I skipped over some slides that
hinted on that is when you look at off
with a finite data set you sometimes see
fluctuations so things are starting to
come out so you watch and as you take
more data is it getting stronger or
weaker at the end of the previous
experimental cycle the large electron
positron Collider which was a earlier
accelerator in the same tunnel there was
a hint of the Higgs boson and a mass
that was at the extreme upper end of
what that machine could do it was a
hundred and 15 GeV or so turned out not
to be there but there was a hint and
there was also a question about having
multiple experiments so one experiment
had some hint
another wasn't sure there was maybe some
slight hint so the response was so run
longer ran longer and they spent the
so-called signal got weaker then we
stopped and then after that 11 years
later I had a discovery it was clearly
shown that that it was not there it was
125 not 115 there's nothing at I so we
go through all those things I'm sorry
it's not just a simple answer but it's a
very serious question
to the additional questions well you've
given us a wonderful overview thanks so
much
a lot of the work and the last part is
not something which I know very much I
learn the law